rené weller die boxlegende begeistert
die massen im boxring welt und
europameister ein idol der 80er jahre
die schönsten frauen lagen ihm zu füßen
und vergessen seine großen kämpfe aber
jetzt führt er den schwersten zeit
seines lebens den nämlich gegen die
unheilbare alzheimer krankheit demenz
wir von bild haben ihn fast über ein
jahr begleitet entstanden ist eine große
dokumentation wenn ich unten bin ist
unten oben die rené weller story heute
abend dann um 20.15 hier bei uns bei btv
kann sich an die harten kämpfe
kommen die tränen wenn ich mit dir hier
lang ihren
frankfurter festhalle der ort an dem er
geschichte geschrieben hat
zweifacher europameister bei den profis
fünfmal deutschlands boxer des jahres
rené weller so kennen wir die boxlegende
spitznamen der schöne rené
wie hast du deine
keine kampfhunde sie
das ist rené weller heute der 68 jährige
leitet seit 2014 an demenz an seine
größten erfolge kann er sich kaum mehr
erinnern und die haben substanz verloren
gegangen und wenn wir uns jetzt diese
veränderung anschauen dann geht es
weiter mit dem auch einher dass wir eine
deutliche leistungssteigerung haben auch
vor allem in dem die fähigkeit im
kurzzeitgedächtnis immer an seiner seite
seine gattin maria
aufopferungsvoll kämpft sie um ihn 24
stunden am tag 7 tage die woche
alles für ihren rené der 68-jährige ist
ein pflegefall
die ärzte führen bellas demenz auf die
vielen schläge auf den kopf zurück
rené weller begeisterte die massen im
boxring
unvergessen sind seine großen erfolge
doch jetzt fitter sein schwersten kampf
den gegen die unheilbare krankheit
alzheimer
[Musik]